well so many questions about uh omicron
and not too many answers we'll try and
furnish you with uh some right now
because all day here on sky news we've
been receiving your questions on the
booster rollout and the omicron variant
itself we've assembled now a panel of
experts to try to answer some of those
questions joining us now are dr yasso
brown gp and diversity lead for the
doctors association also mark jeets
professor of vaccine epidemiology at the
london school of hygiene and tropical
medicine and a member of the sage
subcommittee on modeling and dr mukesh
kapila professor of global health and
humanitarian affairs at the university
of manchester and former director with
the world health organization very good
to have you all here so much to get
through and as you know i'm sure so many
questions about omicron and booster so
let's get to it our first question is
coming from eddie and i'm going to put
this to all of you because there are
many parts to it i suppose at least two
and dr brown if i can start with you
that is question it is this omicron is
more contagious but it also seems milder
why is treatment for cancer and heart
disease being put on the back burner
while the booster program is being
prioritized and of course uh ugps are on
the front line of the the booster
rollout so omicron more contagious but
it seems milder so why then other
treatments put on the back burner
thank you for your question eddie i'd
say japanese study has found that it's
4.2 times more contagious than the delta
variant i know that in south africa
they're coming out and advising that it
is milder but we don't know to what
degree it is and we're finding that um
even though that there is some degree of
evasion that actually there is still um
an importance in getting the booster um
in terms of immune protection um i
understand the anxieties about pausing
the nhs um routine and elective care
that's sort of being discussed at the
moment and that was on um sky just now
um and um you know no one wants to see
um any any more further delays but
actually we've also got to deal uh with
this issue of um understanding how much
um omicron might push and push us back
and that's why i i believe it's being
done let's go professor jeet said take
on that bit of it the idea that omicron
could be more contagious but milder now
a few months ago we were hoping to reach
the position where we not where we would
get a variant that would be perhaps a
little as omicron seems at the moment
something that we might be able to live
with and would spread immunity without
vaccination could this be it or is it
definitely not
unfortunately it's too early to say
whether this variant is milder we have
had reports from south african hospitals
that doctors are seeing um
patients who are less likely to have the
most severe um sort of symptoms but the
problem is that a lot of these patients
they're seeing are re-infections these
are patients who have had covet before
and are now getting infected again
because omicron is able to evade their
immunity whereas in previous waves they
had patients who were getting colbit for
the very first time so what we don't
know is whether these patients are just
having milder disease because they're
re-infections they have a little bit of
immunity which isn't enough to protect
them from getting omicron but is enough
to protect them against the worst
effects it will be i think a few weeks
before we can actually compare like with
like a patient who doesn't have any
immunity who got say delta versus a
patient who didn't have any immunity who
got omicron and see whether it really is
milder at the moment we just have to
conclude that we don't know that yet
unfortunately
dr capulet one thing is for sure even as
we don't know the effect that omicron is
going to have on hospitalizations we do
know the effect that the resources of
the nhs has been turned to this
emergency booster program are going to
lead to more backlogs with already a
pretty dire situation
indeed absolutely and really this is all
about numbers even if omicron
does prove beyond reasonable doubt
that it is milder and
it's going to take time to do that
but because it's highly contagious the
number of people who will get kirk over
19 is going to be measured in in
millions if that happens then by even if
it is not as fatal as previous variants
the sheer numbers involved in terms of
hospitalization are bound to be high
hence the concern
that it is much better to be prudent
there's another factor i think even we
start boosting everyone today
because the number of people in the uk
who haven't yet had even their second
vaccine is not that very high and then
of course it's going to take time to get
to the millions done with the booster
booster job there is bound to be a gap
between boosted immunity and
the burden on
on healthcare systems
here's a question uh following on from
that very interesting point dr kapila
from phil uh asks and i suppose it's
it's a logical uh response to to the
effect of vaccinations so far certainly
two of them and certainly if they're
astrazeneca uh on omicron phil asks what
is the point of vaccine passports if you
can still get covid when fully
vaccinated um
you'll feel on that dr brown
yeah i'm firstly a line of this sort of
questioning um i feel often is about
distrust as well and i think that in
recent years
um i think our leadership does need to
really build that back
um so i am sorry for those that it is
causing anxiety and and feeling of the
liberties and that sort of thing however
um just like we have national passports
that we are able to travel it's the same
sort of line and it's a way of basically
safeguarding
um and safeguarding the protection that
we've built in um with with all the
different mitigations not just
vaccinations
dr cabinet your view on that um if you
can still get covered when you're fully
vaccinated what is the point of
a vaccine passport
well
this whole exercise is about
risk and exposure management
so what that means is that if you've had
your two jobs and hopefully your third
job as well the chances of you getting
a bad coverage
are much reduced now i actually spend a
lot of my time uh in continental europe
in france italy and so on and where the
kovid
pass is in common use going to
restaurants and so on and so forth and
while one can understand some of the
concerns around the freedoms and the
introduction of
of id cards and those kinds of things
quite honestly this is a very small
price
to pay and i think having a a
certificate which says that you've had
your basic immunizations is still
some protection and some security when
using crowded public places
yeah so and there's a very big
difference as you say there between
getting covered and ending up in the
hospital and getting covered and shaking
it off after a few days or a week or so
i've got a very specific question here
for you i'm going to put it to you
professor jeet i think you might be best
placed to answer this for us and it's
from
paul in norwich and he says my partner
and son contracted kovid around three to
four weeks ago does this mean they're
going to be protected through natural
antibodies against omicron i suppose the
thought being that omicron may have been
around you know a bit longer than before
we we first formally identified it so
three to four weeks ago they they both
had covered could they have natural
antibodies against omicron
well the first thing i'd say is if they
were in the uk and it was three to four
weeks ago it was probably not omicron i
mean there was a micron around in the
world but the number of cases in the uk
was probably very very low at that time
so they probably got delta
that means that they do not have very
good protection against omicron i would
say that they're likely to have some
protection so the risk of getting
armicron is less than someone who's
never had covet before at all but i
would say that their risk is not zero
they still have a fair chance of getting
it so i would still you know be careful
going to christmas parties maybe you
know get tested before you go to a big
party just to protect other people there
i mean they might and and please i would
also recommend them to get the booster
if they have
haven't haven't had it yet so they have
a lower risk probably because the
antibodies will give them a bit of
protection but because omicron is so
good at evading the immunity we had from
previous strains they don't have
perfect or even very high protection
just on that professor gene how long do
you have to wait after suffering from
covid to get your booster
well i i
think it's i i think it's it'd be best
to ask um the the gp but i think it's
about three weeks after that
they should get it then dr brown um
it is recommended isn't it to um wait a
while until you you get a booster if you
have been diagnosed as having suffered
from covid recently
um that might just be to suppress having
um
more of a reaction um i i i don't
actually um
want my mind about what the exact um
time frame of distance is i'm sure it's
there i'm sure it's on the government
website but just to stay with you dr
brown i want to
put this next question uh to you all
with omicron rising a question coming
from what's up it's a question on many
thousands many millions of people's lips
how likely is it that we will go into
another lockdown which if i can turn
that question around is do you think
plan b and uh what may follow if it's
plan c do you think they will work
against omicron or might we need to go
full lockdown dr brown
yeah i mean
i have thought about this um and i would
say that actually we're not a covered
naive society anymore so
um we have not just exposure but we've
got learning from from what we've always
seen so and what we want to do is make
sure that we are protecting the most
vulnerable with the information that
we've had the learning that we've had
but also put into the mitigations that
we know work so hand you know hand
hygiene face masks social distancing um
companies to look into ventilation asked
to think about ventilation um as well as
engaging in the vaccine program and so
just i think we just all need to take
that responsibility and apply our
knowledge um and actually
we would probably won't in my opinion i
think because of the mitigations that we
have in the and where we are we're not
killed naive i i don't think um that uh
i think the lockdown is sort of a really
last resort but obviously we've got
people here from sage and taboo that
would definitely be able to
advise on this further well let's have a
look with dr cabula about that um
let me put it another way presumably
another full lockdown can never really
be entirely ruled out
well
knockdowns can't be ruled out but uh
with the current state of knowledge that
we have
and all the tools that are disposal
and the current spread i do not think a
decision on lockdowns today if taken
today
would be
justified and remember also that the
experience of last two years shows that
all that lockdowns do
is postpone or delay the spread of
infections so
what happens is when you do lockdowns
and people are not exposed to virus
and if they haven't have their
jab then they will
certainly not get the virus but as soon
as they go out into the real world
they'll get it if they've not been
vaccinated so what that means is that
lockdowns never have been the answer
and thank god we are we've moved on a
great deal from that particular state i
would be extremely surprised if a
lockdown decision argument is made by
sage or others uh as being the imminent
and i think if the
booster program goes even half as much
half as well as it is uh
as a target indicates then i would very
much doubt there will be a lock down or
should be a long time okay professor g
you you give me your thoughts on that
briefly and i'm going to add in because
there's so many good questions here i
want to get as many as i i can in here
and this is a very specific question and
i'm very interested in it in that i'm in
this position if i've had two
astrozenica vaccines can i get the fisa
vaccine as my booster i've actually had
that
and how much protection does that mixing
and matching offer
well i in fact the boosters that are
being given are all pfizer and modern
vaccines and these have been tested in
trials now with people who have had
either astrazeneca or pfizer vaccines
and they've been found to give very good
protection to either group of people so
this mixing and matching actually works
it's been found to be safe and give very
good protection in trials so definitely
um the mix and match um as you put it um
does work
um on the question of the love
happy to for you to continue so sorry i
interrupted you a thought on lockdown
potential or of another lockdown
yeah i mean i i can't say because that's
really the government's decision to make
and i don't have special insight into
what they might decide but i would say
well they have to take many things into
consideration the health impact which um
the signs don't look great because there
is going to be a big wave of omicron but
they also have to take into account the
economy the effect on people's lives and
mental health and so forth i would say
we're in a better position than we were
a year ago or because we have the
vaccines and even though we know that
this variant is good at evading vaccines
we know that if people get the booster
then that does
boost their protection up to a level
that does help to protect them against
omicron so we are in a better position
if people get boosted than we were
at the start of the pandemic and dr
brown you must be getting asked that a
lot i suppose about people coming in
given the millions upon millions of
people in the uk who've had two
astrazeneca jobs now as we hear from
professor jeet they're um getting uh
pfizer and modern
asking that
precise question am i still as protected
if i've had three fisas or three
modernists
uh yeah um jcvi have basically done
studies to show about mixed vaccinations
and they've approved it um and um also
mhri have approved um visa
visa astrazeneca and moderna as booster
vaccines and so uh generally we would be
reassuring people that mixed
vaccinations are fine if they have
medical reasons to have astrazeneca then
that will be continued
got a question i'm trying to squeeze as
many as
i say got a question here from dan he
says he's got covid right now
poor udan and assumes it is the delta
variants
not sure he asks if people who recover
from delta can succumb to omicron
immediately afterwards uh particularly
as he came to see people at christmas as
so many millions are so he's got delta
is he in danger still then from omicron
immediately afterwards do we know
i'm
guessing we don't do dr capula
well i think if you had a previous
strain then obviously you've got some
immunity you've got t-cell immunity as
well not just the antibodies so
one would on first principle i guess
would say that surely your body is fired
up immunologically speaking but of
course you're vulnerable to omicron
because it's a completely different
uh variant when you would get your
omnicron having just got your delta i'm
not sure i have the knowledge to give
the answer to that if anyone ever
if anyone else does but yes you are
vulnerable to omicron even if you have
the delta wires
and professor g dom that i suppose we go
back to whatever the situation is after
your natural infection do get your
vaccination as well get your booster as
well
yes definitely in fact there have been
studies looking at antibodies showing
that people who have had a previous
infection and then got vaccinated have
even more protection than people who
just had either natural infection or
just vaccination
and uh dr brown a quick thought a
specific one and again you must see
patients in this
situation antoinette is pregnant had her
first dose six weeks ago and she asked
why the government isn't reducing the
period between first and second doses
because she obviously wants to protect
herself she's pregnant and had a first
dose six weeks ago
yeah well first of all congratulations
tonight
um and what i would say is it's really
difficult situation um it's um i'm just
thinking back to what christopher t said
when um we've talked about these vaccine
gaps and maybe going against the fisa 21
day recommendation it's about it's a
public health management it's a public
health approach basically and it's about
health equity it's about looking at how
long
it will last within our immune system or
help our immune system rather
and also it's going to be about a
vaccine supply as well
brilliant stuff thank you so much we
packed so much in the short time
available thank you so much my esteemed
panel dr brown professor dr kapila we
are eternally grateful thank you